have fun watching the fight fight I did
hell so bad for a while did I did to us
broken I love him and I did too but I
felt bad because I think that Tyson Fury
is a problem Wilder will never solve
never and I don't know a mess and I also
think that Anthony I think Wilder in
that moment became number three in the
in me I think Joshua does the same thing
to him I don't know who does it that
style I mean definitely a closer fight
now that his Austral but Joshua is a
better matchup for him but yeah he did
that he did the problem the problem is
and you know experts have said this all
the time going up to it go at the end of
the day you know Wilders not the best
boxer he has that he has the gift of God
but when it comes down to X's and O's
and fundamentals he doesn't have it so
fury scan was like cool put you on your
back foot or even better than you inside
out there goes well it goes back to what
you were saying about quarterbacks in
the NFL if you ran really well in
college and you're a runner the defense
because they're professional get out
they could get away we're just gonna
make you pass in the pocket and read the
deep we're making you work on your
weakness and what that's what he did and
so he promised we experience that's
experience and that's being a great
boxer who went oh I know I know what
he's bad at fighting off his back foot
right I mean get him moving backwards
it's crazy man I felt so bad for him I
didn't care about the money none of that
I felt I felt so bad for me too
I was like you don't because I was like
oh he's a shell like he doesn't want to
be in there I'm like oh no this is it he
kept doing the weirdest thing he kept he
would stand her and kept adjusting he
kept touching this part his right hand
and I was like I've never seen him do
that that's why I thought did he hurt
his hand but it was like I
he just wasn't you just wasn't there I
think he just realized he just I felt
funny I wanted to stop it so bad right
remember when he was sitting down on the
bench and he was just he looked
depressed he didn't wanna be in there
man he just didn't want to do it he that
happen so unfortunate happened for him
on a big night against us happens
sometimes it does happen to the greats
yeah and if it does you won't know with
him we knew and I was like a plan
I'm telling you I looked up when when he
took off that mask I looked at my family
ah [ __ ] really
right away I went oh that's my grass my
dog wash
that doesn't look like the [ __ ] water
we're used to seeing I well man he looks
scared he doing half of the oh I bet
$4,500 up wait wait why why
but he might you might be content and
met he's good men financially everything
I think he's good
was he if was he afraid of the weight
difference no cuz he put on weight which
was a bad sign my brother I like I have
some inside sources and they told me all
these things that made me decide to take
Wilder and I wish I didn't listen to him
because obviously costs me money but
then while and fear is my favorite
fighter I've always said that he's my
favorite fighters I hated been against
them but when you look at the things
leading up to it you know while our fear
is doing exactly what the fight in
Wilder was the one we should have been
worried about putting on the weight my
brother goes I'm telling you man don't
bet on it
while they're putting on all that muscle
it's not good it's a bad sign yeah how
you shut your fat mouth dude
well but um how about a strainer because
I think it was his a tire that he wore
it to the ring tired amount and also he
also goes I would have stopped the fight
the other coach doing that that was very
smart to stop a shoe shopping too before
three here's my prompt to when they go
the stool and he goes back him up right
hand I'm like that's the coaching at
this yeah I couldn't hear cuz I was
watching that hold up right hand back on
that you're coach Jack him up what about
the him didn't didn't annihilate it what
what about Tyson imposing his will but
it will hit the [ __ ] right that's your
could they didn't have they weren't
saying anything to him it looked like I
couldn't just knock him up throw the
right hand back him up throw the right
hand but also there's listen [ __ ] you
know well we see a rematch it's in their
closets as I thought Eddie her and was
talking this morning on the BTB TV sit
out and let these two fight Joshua [ __ ]
you [ __ ] hey you better find boring up
hey of course not sir so this thing
called contract
yeah but why they have to remit they
have to before he fights anybody can't
yeah come on papa
yeah so they have to unless wow so it's
up to a while
not up to whiff so if Wilder does Nam
good I'm gonna move on because I can't
win that fight
he's chance him ever fight him again are
not good cuz fury go cool thanks bro
and then he's gonna go fight Joshua
probably two or three times and make a
fortune biggest fight in Las Vegas you
know the best
yeah she fighting baby cuz it's all how
dare you know the big fighting against
the holds [ __ ] twelve thousand yeah
Josh we can fight a [ __ ] the UPS men
sell 80,000 ticket team out with him and
Fury's gonna it's the biggest fight
boxes by far and when I saw Tyson I mean
on that stand with that king's throne I
thought to myself boxing is so back
they've made the octet he's made the
heavyweight division so exciting and I
think what you're gonna see now is more
yellow weights will show up it's gonna
get a diving big to be fair it's the
three of them mate but heavyweight back
yes
Joshua Wilder and Tyson made made it
cool yeah the three of them not just wow
these last two fights were dodged [ __ ]
awful no one couldn't Wilder sit out
even though he's in contract couldn't he
say I'm injured I want to sit this out
whatever it is now he's got a day after
that's contract yeah
yes I think 30 days to go I want the
rematch and Eddie Hearn was talking to
us he goes well we have to fight pool of
by contract we have to do that that's
the mandatory so we're gonna do that in
like like next two months he goes and if
it's up to us we'll fight during the
summer we're ready to do that right now
make the deal and why and so but the
interview on BBC goes if you're the
promoter of wild or what he in doing is
different story because if I'm working
with Wilder
I say you take the rematch because
that's where the most money if you don't
take the rematch you're never gonna get
it and you need the money got to do it
so yeah of course he's gonna do it well
you make 50 million dollars $39 I don't
know but it just is just such a bummer
because I don't want to see it the
yelling it annihilated the first fight
it's like yeah of course and but when
when when Wilder said I was dealing with
some stuff coming in do we know anything
insider
no injuries maybe some you know I I'm I
don't know doesn't matter doesn't matter
does it
be fair he's dealing stuff everybody's
dealing with [ __ ] doesn't matter unless
it was like yo seriously I broke both my
hands or I broke my jaw I got knocked
out the night before but it's if it was
that serious here to come out by now see
how you haven't heard anything nothing
it's not that serious because because
I'm telling you his team would have went
on damage control and somebody came out
that night Mike we want let everybody
know he blew his dick off lighting
fireworks Thursday night was a fight
cologne was like oh damn that makes
sense give us the trill he just his
house is real quiet his head wasn't he
didn't want to do do you didn't want to
be there man
it was awful to see if he comes in too
far by the way he was in the first fight
it matters I don't wanna see it you
can't solve the problem sure it's too
good too hard to hit man too [ __ ]
hard to hit yeah he looked amazing
I was sure eat well I loved watch him I
prefer watching fights at home but I've
been fighting to a fight to paying for
that would you make a prediction on that
Wilder me Walter I'm sorry not what you
need fury Joshua yeah I think fury beat
them he's a slight favorite too
yeah yeah nothin but yeah no one's
beating fears the best everybody on the
planet bars so awkward so weird those
big arms are just so good he's so
[ __ ] good 31 how old is he yeah 31 so
damn good that's crazy he's got so much
that's so young how about retires to he
woulda lost this one he played saved by
a retired guy how about his dad called
it to a tee exacto was gonna happen he's
like in a shouting match yeah on TV his
brothers at Giant he's got two brothers
that are jealous huh
no no giant six six no I've been asking
your bet so once I hold on once it's
constant cousin yeah and he's
professional boxer that's right [ __ ]
so when discuss isn't more so once his
cousins watch it yeah who's a beast put
your hand down but yeah now his cousin's
a great fighter is he yeah really good
the brothers are both big kids of just
giant kids no no mm-hmm
no big fat 6:4 nope nope that's his
cousin that's supposed to be his brother
Tom maybe not I don't know that's AC
shame down there
that's his brother right there let me
see how tall he is shortened from six
foot so these are probable breyer Labre
within camp with him you know you read
calendar hey you know the actor too much
so when I say I've been around him I've
actually been around 20 years old
half-brother oh that's his brother right
there this guy's is half brother Tommy
fury Jane's probably real brother other
than the whole family then he has one
more
yeah then his dad was a bare-knuckle
fighter Christ where'd he get his height
his dad stats huge dad's enormous yeah
but his actual brother they like manage
him that that's him there Shane great
guy but he's like you know six much fat
huh here's one more yeah what about the
guy with the long hair there that that
one the one with the long hair down
there is that same guy yeah let's say
okay his cousin is 6xe he was sparring
with I think his cousin yes kai forgets
the cousin's name oh that's him there
the is it
Huy that's right hue use this picture
yeah and Huey had a big fight almost
[ __ ] you DB almost beat the guy but got
screwed over decision
yeah Huey for you fury the Beast well
that didn't help a vacuum that's right a
lot of people thought he won that stud
yeah a lot of people thought he won that
is he who's sick it's too small for
these guys know who sticks a little
beast but yeah he's a little small we
talking about fury 20 I think this and
all that then against height - yeah but
politics - like you're like Wilders Paul
man and give me too much too much too
much he's a beast uh man you never know
6315 yeah he's really good he's amazing
does he come out of Lohman janko's camp
I don't think so 33 though stacked but
the Big M let's see it's gonna be
interesting I really want to see this
I'm very excited about boxing again yeah
you're getting that Wilder fury trilogy
though so don't get too excited just the
way the boxing world works that's where
they're gonna make their money it's a
bummer because you really want see
Joshua Fury badly you could see it at
then the year you can see me buy that at
least I was seeing it I don't know maybe
hopefully her and says they want it I'll
tell you this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]